and it's funny because I there's one
blip at the end of the movie that I am
in and as a result of that I still get
residuals and every time I open up my
residual check I'm like damn like I
didn't have to get my money back and
they're still paying me for a movie I
simply got cut out of you down hello
everyone welcome back for a brand new
episode of Collider ladies night I am so
excited to be sitting with Michelle
Monica how are you doing I am really
well we're just revisiting our our past
interview journey at Dave & Buster's
everyone knows how much I love like
games and stuff like that so that junket
made my day and also I just I haven't
thought about the movie Gus and for yeah
you know that time when we spoke I was
sitting there with like I think like a
look I love that movie by the way she's
a lunatic and that baby's gonna be a
lunatic just don't understand why she
has to live here that's just while she's
pregnant she's all along I don't want
her in the house anymore
this mean - you guys argue really makes
me question whether or not you can
handle raising this kid I'm sorry you're
giving your baby to them oh yeah your
mind yeah yeah I really loved that year
that year and I was surprised how much
it really stuck with me you know when
you go to those festivals you've seen a
million different things exactly
exactly now that was a really great
experience you know with Jesse McCormick
wrote that and it was one of the first
times I that I'd worked with another
female on-screen that had such great
chemistry with and the first of being
really probably Malin Akerman in the
Heartbreak Kid who ended up becoming one
of my very best friends who I love and
adore but Radha Mitchell I I got to work
with her in this movie Gus and we just
had the best time together and I forgot
I was like oh wow chicks can actually
have chemistry because you're always
hearing about oh they have great
chemistry or they you know and it's
always and it's always between a man and
a woman yeah and there's nothing sexual
about it but it's just the idea that
they have like a very nice you know the
connecting his actors creatively and Ben
anyway so I thought it was I was just
thinking about that movie yesterday so
it's so funny yeah
that you're bringing it up I also think
about the Heartbreak Kid all the time I
think I was a really fun I think it's
such an underrated comment like no one
gives it and like mom is so she really
it's she's so brilliant you know a funny
story about that and I'm sure what she
and I have talked about it but I
initially had gone in to read for her
role and and then I got the audition
went really well and then I think they
called me up and they were like there's
an actress that came in for it they
really liked her for the role would you
be open to doing the other role and I
like I liked the role of its at Maria
yeah Miranda yeah and I liked the role
of Miranda a lot time you know whatever
and so that's the story behind that it
was you know it's funny how things work
out and then from the moment that we
that we met we clicked and we've just
been fast friends ever since over the
years because I know this happens with
some folks out there do you find that
you and Malin are up for similar roles
or is there anyone out there that you
find that happening I don't think she
and I are up for similar roles I feel
like she she and I have different career
paths or we do things at different times
what is something I remember one move
the Brokeback Mountain I remember going
in for that and it was really really I
think Michelle Williams ended up getting
in the role but I think I remember
having read that and I was shooting
North Country at the time and it was one
of those things that like I had a day
off and I had a chance to go in for
Brokeback Mountain but I think that's
what I can remember I can't remember if
I'm always up against like certain
people I actually make it a rule of
thumb - I never want to know I don't I
don't ever ask I don't ever want to know
who else I'm up against because any time
I walk into the room I'm just really
honestly up against myself so you really
are though I mean I honestly think
that's a really healthy approach I hate
I think we put so much pressure on
ourselves as women in this industry it's
already hard enough I think we in it
inevitably get pitted against each other
anyway so I think if anything that
you can do to actively control that I
think we should do and I've always tried
to do that and and I think it allows me
to go in more relaxed and just thinking
I'm the only one walking into the room
oh I can imagine it sounds like the much
better prayer yeah one of the cool
things about your career is you've done
a little of everything you've every type
of movie every genre I'm curious when
you were first starting out like when
you had that dream of making it in
Hollywood yeah what career path did you
picture for yourself you're thinking I'm
gonna be an action hero or you know what
I've never had one and I still don't
have why not I think because I didn't
actually really have this dream this
really clear dream of being an actor I
never set out to really do it I studied
journalism in college I really wanted to
be a journalist much like yourself and
it wasn't until I was modeling it's kind
of how I got myself through school I
started doing commercials they were
paying the bills I got an audition for
this show called the young Americans and
I didn't have an agent and then I so I
was like oh well I should get an agent
because I've got this job you know and
then one thing led to another and then I
thought oh maybe this is what I'm meant
to do and then you know you don't have
you know the pick of the litter when
you're starting out really I mean you
just you have to work hard and persevere
and for me it was just a I think more
about proving to myself that this is
what I wanted to do or what I was meant
to do and I think it was really only
when I really felt like there were
people in the industry that I was
working with it were really giving me a
lot of encouragement and a lot of
support I think it was like a I had done
a small role in unfaithful but I
remember Richard Gere being just so
incredibly supportive during that shoot
and it was like giving me thumbs up in
between takes and I thought to myself
I'm like wow I mean that's amazing like
maybe I should do this like Richard Gere
just doesn't have to give me a thumbs up
you know so it was like things like that
and
it was like you know I didn't age and
said well let's just try she's still
with him still with her today her name
is Bonnie and I think it was you know
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang was probably my
biggest that was my big break when I
really reflect upon it Harry Lockhart
[Laughter]
spiders
you know I'd done a show actually called
Boston Public and I remember I had gone
in for a role I didn't get it but the
creator he wrote an arc for me on that
show and that was the first time that I
had worked with multiple directors and I
remember you know JJ Abrams said it was
he'd you know a people that I've worked
with sense than in stuff you know I
started out with there basically and
they were all giving me you know I'd
never studied acting so I learned on
every single job so for me I don't think
I actually had the liberty or the time
to be like oh I want my career to be
like this I've always wanted my career
to do well first of all to be fun right
okay but I've I I didn't grow up
watching movies either
okay this I'm giving you a really long
smile eyes this and I always I keep
racking up follow-up questions and I
guarantee you I maybe remember well okay
that's okay good but it's sort of one of
those things where I'm like you don't
know it until it hits you right so you
know is that that should Boston public
was wow that was really great that was
drama then I had the opportunity to do
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang and I was like oh I
can be a little funny you know I was
like oh that's great and then that led
to North Country or Heartbreak Kid and
so as long as I am continually kind of
striving to do different things with
different people in
you know really exploring all the genres
big and small I can't tell you what I'm
gonna do tomorrow you know what I mean
it'll just be I'll follow my gut
instinct you're definitely doing just
that okay you you grew up not watching
many movies no it's the movie that
changed that for you oh my gosh I would
say Julia Roberts Dolly Parton steel
magnolias thank you
I should have known I was supposed to be
an actress then because my cousins
I have so many female cousins every
family get-together you know one of us
would be Sally Field one of us would be
Julia Roberts one of us would be Daryl
Hannah you know Olympia Dukakis all of
them and we would play that that
cemetery scene like you know I you know
that I won't do it but I want to and
sometimes I still do
Shelby was right but that was that movie
still to this day it was so ahead of its
time there were such star power and like
profound like powerful women in that in
that film and it was heartfelt and it
was there was a camaraderie and there
was a sisterhood should we remake it I
don't know maybe yeah exactly and and
it's probably going to be announced
tomorrow because it's out there in the
universe now but you know that was that
was one of those things and then I you
know I did plays in high school mostly
because I didn't do sports I wasn't
athletic and I loved that but you know I
grew up in a town of seven hundred
people so you don't like you're very I
think you're limited maybe in the dreams
that you somehow have if you don't feel
like that that's just like a it just
didn't feel like a reality to me so how
do you go from a small town to that
first opportunity where you're still
living in that small
town when you got that offer the offer
to audition for that show no I was
living in I was living in New York but I
had I'd gone to Chicago to mod arts to
go to college and in order to put myself
through college to study journalism I
did catalog modeling so I worked for
Target and Montgomery Ward's and I and I
did all of all the above and I would
work during the day and then I take
night classes at night and I traveled
you know during my semesters off I
modeled abroad and did all of that and
then I realized in my senior year I was
like I don't want to be and I don't want
to be a journalist I realized there's
gonna have to be a one-man fan go back
to places like Ohio and I'm like no man
I just got out of there I like the city
and I thought you know what I'm just
gonna throw caution to the wind and move
to New York I had a really overwhelming
sense why New York because I could still
model there okay and because I really
want I'd always I modeled a little bit
throughout the years in New York and I
just I loved that city I loved the
melting pot it I always had a sense of
and I still feel it when I go back there
like it's that one city that I've been
to that I've obviously spent a lot of
time in live there for 12 years but like
you can come from anywhere
like any background any socio-economic
background anywhere in the world and you
have as equal of a shot as anybody else
to make it and I came from Timbuktu a
town from a farm girl from like 700
people and I and I felt like I could
make it there if I worked hard I really
did and I always saw that in all the
people that I knew because I had such a
wide range of friends there that came
from all over the world that I felt like
I could live whatever potential I
decided I wanted to be and as I was
modeling I started doing commercials I
had good luck I started doing like I did
a Tampax commercial secret deodorant
commercial you know and then the the
audition came by and I got it and then I
got my agents and then that was it so
speaking to my New York love and heart
right now New York or LA so when I was
reading up that you had gone the New
York yes I was pleasantly surprised by
that I think I was I think it was good I
actually encourage people who are
starting out I know a few young actors
who are doing really well that are like
I don't know if I should move to LA I
really like it New York I'm like stay in
New York like I think like as you're
kind of honing your skill I think
there's something nice about you know
being in the industry but not being at
such a young age to having to have the
industry be around you 100% at the time
like I think there's there's so there's
so much to learn in New York to be
honest that I think just that kind of
exposure to everyday life and people
there serves you probably better as an
actor starting out then you know maybe
being in the industry that makes me
happy I love that speaking of maybe
young actors out there one thing I think
is always beneficial for someone else to
hear is how someone in your position
kind of gets over a bump in the road and
the one thing I was reading about is
what was it like 2005 you had a couple
movies where you were cut out of the
movie yes at that point in your career
like how do you deal with some how do
you first react and then we get over
saying you know honestly the first
reaction cuz I had was new to the
industry and it was true I was in a
movie called Constantine with Keanu
Reeves and had a pretty significant role
and then I they call it was like Francis
Lawrence actually he called he was a
gentleman he wrote me a letter he called
they felt terrible they just had to
remove the storyline for whatever reason
but for me I honestly the first my first
reaction was do I have to pay them back
like I actually thought I had to pay
them back like I did their cutting you
out of the movie I thought I was gonna
be responsible for it
you had their money and I was like I was
like didn't have any money I was broke
you know and I was like to have to like
I'm just like I don't have the money and
it's funny because I there's one blip at
the end of the movie that I am in and as
a result of that I still get residuals
and every time I open up my residual
check I'm like damn like I didn't have
to get my money back and they're still
paid me for a movie I simply got cut out
of you know
[Applause]
I think the first thing that you have to
realize and secondly I got cut out of
another movie called Syriana but the
great news about that was is that I
ended up getting a handwritten note from
George Clooney's so now I've got that in
my back pocket but it was another thing
about storyline and I mentioned both of
them because I think it's really
important to understand you have to take
your ego out of it and really understand
that if you're getting cut out of
something I can probably more times more
often than not it's a result of just too
much storyline too much narrative too
much content it's not necessarily a
reflection of the performance that you
gave so I think that's the first thing
to always remember it's like you know
you're gonna get cut you know scenes get
cut down all the time I'm shootin Xand I
think even Messiah or other projects you
know there are certain scenes that
ultimately just have to go for time
purposes so I think if you can just
realize like that's just a rite of
passage getting cut out of something
it's at least you've got that something
and that's another rite of passage do
you know what I mean and so it's always
you got to kind of like stop and get
past the knee-jerk reaction yeah yeah
realizes that moment where it's like oh
my god I told everybody it was gonna be
in a movie and then all of a sudden like
you're not of that moving you're like oh
god that sucks you know but look at you
now you got your note you guys and I'll
tell you what the the audition that I
had had for Constantine was a really
good audition and that tape made it into
the hands of JJ Abrams and as a result
of that that that got me the role in MA
and in my three his men it meant it got
me yeah he was like you know somebody
said Francis sent me your audition tape
I saw it it was like a really fresh
voice I never saw you I had you you know
and I went through you know I auditioned
with the casting director and you know
Tom and I did an audition as well and
you know I got the role so everything
happens for a reason you know
I gotta keep reminding myself that all
the time and it's worth it yes it is you
remember the very first role you are
flat-out offered and kind of what that
felt like oh gosh okay
Wow just flat-out didn't have to
audition or anything first time that
okay that's a really that's a great
question and I can tell you without even
knowing what it was it felt great but I
will say let me see so let me see North
Country audition for Mission Impossible
oh oh no I auditioned I was gonna say
maid of honor but I auditioned for that
as well it's um maybe maybe source code
maybe somewhere my OH eagle-eye Rachel
Holloman look in the window would you
risk your life for your son okay
yeah I think Eagle Eye might have been
the first the first one that feels about
right
visually remember seeing that movie IMAX
theatre in the land center theaters yeah
I would say I would say that but there's
something that I have to say about that
because about getting a role that you
have an audition for I really as sort of
nerve-wracking the audition process can
be I actually really embrace it and
because it's an opportunity to prove to
myself that I am right for the role so I
like the idea of going in and reading
and collaborating with the director the
writer whoever the casting director and
then if you get the job you're like wow
my instincts were right okay that's
great that's a great I'm gonna keep
going on that you know that path and
then you know every day I get to work
like that and that's a real privilege of
knowing when you rock up on the first
day you're like okay they really do want
me here whereas if you're offered jobs
now and fortunately now I've I'm in that
position which is great but there is
always that element of me like I've done
all that prep work typically for the
most part on my own and still
collaborating with the director or
writer but they haven't actually seen my
work or my interpretation until we're in
front of the camera so there's at
element of like maybe they will maybe
then maybe what their idea is different
than what my idea is so I like going in
and kind of earning I don't
mind auditioning and kind of earning
that like that take onyx it's a lot of
sense has really the roles that you've
sought out for yourself changed over the
years and why Messiah right now I don't
think the roles have sought out I think
that that the the roles that have sought
me out or maybe different I don't know I
mean I'm guess I'm always looking for I
there is an element of I like strong
women obviously I mean I'm surrounded by
them you know I really veer I like I
hate to use the word flawed women
anymore because I think like we're just
human and we don't refer to men as being
flawed on camera you're like oh hi you
play a really flawed man you're like no
they just play a human being like a man
and like a woman like if she's doing
things that are you know I don't know
questionable it's like well you know
exactly so I guess there's that element
of that like I just really feel like I
like to play people that you're
relatable people that are you know I'm
talking about specifically drama here
obviously not that women in comedy
aren't really to believe there but I
think you get the picture
so it's an element I never really know
what it what it's going to be or how a
character is gonna find me and you know
it's also you know I'm I'm very aware
that like the stars align in which you
know a particular project gets dropped
in your lap you know I just recently
worked with Zoe lister-jones so I'm not
gonna be able to hold back yeah I know
and we'll get there but like just for
that you know it's like I if you would
have told me a year ago like you're
gonna do a remake of the craft I would
have been like I don't think so you know
what I mean yeah so I don't I can't it's
hard for me to navigate like say you
know look at a crystal ball and tell you
what I'm gonna do but like here Zoe
lister-jones who I respect immensely I
think she's got a really strong voice
right now in the industry she reimagined
it and it was like I read and I was like
oh well yeah
I'm absolutely doing a remake of the
craft it's funny when I say that to some
people were like okay you know you're
doing ready there but she's brilliant
it's super contemporary and timely she's
been very smart about it and so I'm
excited so in terms of Messiah I'll
answer your question now because I went
off on a tangent I do that I do that I
think for me you know I had just come
off the path I wasn't anticipating going
back to work that early and but I was
open to reading it I know James McTigue
one of our directors and Michael Patroni
sent me all 10 episodes and you know I
read them within you know a day half a
day I mean it was just just such a great
page-turner and I think it by the time I
finished it I think the first thing I
did was like I called my husband and I
was like so that time that I said I was
gonna take off I don't think it's
happening you know that that thing that
was just sent to me it's so good
and I think what struck me about it was
just the global scope of it and that
really excited me because I had never
been involved in a project that I
thought could potentially reach so many
people in such a productive way in a
really thoughtful way in a provocative
way and that the series in terms of what
it what it deals with and talks about
and your belief systems and what you
project and you reflect upon the world
inhabited so many different points of
view and and cultures and perspectives
and it wasn't just a specific Western
point of view there's a sense of like
pride that I have with that I'm like
that's really that's an important show
to make you know and and to have the
home be Netflix where it's in 190
countries was really exciting and and on
top of all of the characters you know
which I've responded to you know I loved
this role that Michael created of this
woman who felt like a very real woman
who
has this really uncompromising
[Music]
professional life and yet she lives a
very insular existence and is suffering
quietly and I was really excited about
to get you know to peel back the onion
on that and explore her he's come out of
nowhere and we don't know who he is
what do we know about him he's leading
desperate people so this is a cult we
don't know who he's associated with he
could be creating an army or he could be
leading them to their death it's all
about like who is this guy and I love
the fact that we don't really get
anything from his perspective it's just
everybody around him and it kind of so
brilliant makes the audience play along
in a sense - yeah I mean I think that's
what's so great you just nailed it it's
it feels very participatory as an as an
audience like it forces you to look at
yourself and your own life experience in
your own belief system and then you get
to make the choice and that's why I'm
also really encouraging because he
doesn't call himself a divine entity or
that or
you know he doesn't call himself
anything he just exists to be there and
really whole is a mirror to yourself and
I encourage people to watch it with a
group of people because it's not a
singular viewing experience because you
really want to dissect each episode as
you watch it I find and I find that you
know kind of the connective tissue the
show is that all the characters are
searching much like we all are right
we're all looking for hope or the truth
or salvation or actual freedom you know
physical freedom is some of the
characters in the show and so you're
going to connect with one of those
characters depending on where you are in
the world
and you're gonna go on that journey with
them for ten episodes and that person's
actions and the way that they perceive
it will you'll your opinions and your
perceptions of them will change as you
go in that journey with them so watch it
with a group and then would you also
recommend doing the binge watch or
taking the time to watch one and you
know it's it's it's interesting that you
say that because I think if you can
watch a few you know what I mean and
then and then sit when like we literally
have an honest conversation about
because my husband and I watched it he
had no idea what to expect I didn't tell
him anything about the show for like a
year and he was like whoa this is this
is unbelievable and he had different
takeaways than I did and I had different
takeaways even from when I had read it
so even as someone who knew what was
going on you know getting to see the
performances of my co-stars and seeing
how powerful they are there so that are
also incredible in the show it got me so
excited like no we need to sit down and
talk about this and about a week later
like we were still talking about it
after we benched it so it's a
conversation starter I'm not even all
the way through because I didn't dare
walk in this room for this interview
knowing the end because I don't want
yeah yeah exactly that's true good good
it was very tempting to just burn
through all of it yes I have to go back
to the craft right now because we're
talking for Collider ladies night right
now and on that one you get to work with
a whole group of just like powerhouse
ladies as well and it excites me so much
so can you describe the atmosphere on a
set and how that bones yeah so you know
it's terrific group of young actresses
you know Zoe lister-jones of course her
GP who she always works with who female
produce it was just a really like female
production and it was fantastic I mean
it was really just it was you know it's
the craft so you know what it's a bad
and they you know we had which is coming
in and saging the place and doing
seances and Ouija board and all that
stuff you know and I'm a little bit that
of that gal you know who likes all that
well I don't know if I believe in like
it
all but there was definite there was
some witchiness going on and it was so
fabulous because what else you're gonna
get away with doing that it's like and
that was work you know it was work so
and so he's just really smart and and it
was just a great it was just a great
time being on that set I'm so spooky but
also really like timely and relevant you
know in terms of what it's about and and
how she reimagined it so I'm in its Blum
house and I've been wanting to work with
Jason for a while now so it was great to
finally get to collaborate yeah so would
you describe it as a remake or
reimagining I would say we reimagine
okay yeah I'm digging that yeah I'm just
a massive fan of that original so I'm so
excited I can't even you know they told
me I have the wrap-up sign going now so
really we always like to yeah we like
wow I know that was so fast and that's
what happens when I write all these
don't look at them no I'm out of time
but we do like to end with some
rapid-fire question okay I'm like
totally random things that we call
collateral oh yeah fun what are you
watching on TV right now the crown okay
Oh Olivia Colman Oh what's your favorite
movie of 2019
oh gosh book-smart that's the right
answer
yeah what role of yours would you like
to revisit ah oh harmony faith lane from
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang for sure oh my god
yeah there's there needs to be a sequel
there yeah that would be a fun one do
you have any pets I do I have an
in-court bunny named bubbles oh my god
hurts melting right last one for you
what is the most important Lee oh gosh
the impulsive thing that I've done
recently I impulsive thing that I've
done recently I don't even know how to
eat it I have no idea to answer that I
can't think of anything that I've done
in born what what is your biggest
problem is shopping that's been Impala
cuz I'm just trying to get it done so
it's the
the it's that's just fine it's you know
what I mean it's just like I'll just get
it done just give it like that's a very
appropriate impose I know but it's not
it's not well thought-out and it's just
not financially sound so like it's not
like you know what I mean it's the
holidays everyone appreciate everything
so much for your today today everybody
out there that was too fast I know right
another half-hour Messiah available
Netflix first thing in 2020 January
first check it out again thank you for
your time thank you for watching this
episode don't leave without liking and
sharing it we'll see you soon with more
ladies
[Applause]
[Music]